are hundreds of scholarships now
available to local high school seniors
as well as current college students for
the years ahead
joining us now via zoom to highlight
some of the opportunities is kelsey
rodman
she's with the public education
foundation kelsey thanks for being with
us
thank you so much for having me let's
get right into it first how can students
determine
which scholarships they are eligible for
well first off so they're going to go to
our foundation's website the public
education foundation
you can find it at the pef.org
and if you go to our programs you'll
find the scholarships plus program
and you'll actually be able to apply
online all of our applications we have
over 300 active opportunities right now
they are all online and we have a handy
search bar like a google search or
anything else that allows you to search
keywords to find the opportunities that
best fit you
whether that be you're a current college
student or your current high school
senior
potentially you want to study a specific
area of
education such as engineering maybe you
want to go to a two-year school
a four-year school in-state out-of-state
whatever the case may be that search bar
is going to be your best friend
and we know kelsey college can be so
expensive you think about a four-year
university and what that means cost-wise
so for the student looking for all those
scholarships and grants can they
actually find
and apply for multiple scholarships
absolutely i would say the more the
merrier
for instance last year we had one
student win 10 scholarships
you miss 100 of the shots you don't take
as long as you qualify for the
scholarship and you can read that in the
scholarship description i would say you
have the green light to apply for as
many as you would like
kelsey you sound like my high school
basketball coach right there you miss
the shots you don't take
very good advice when is the deadline to
submit those applications
so for our scholarships on our website
majority of them will close january 31st
2021 at 11 59 so make sure that's two
months away but that will come
quicker than we can imagine so don't
wait on it
you can start applying today again on
our website thepef.org
advice to heed don't wait be proactive
and get all over it we really appreciate
your time and that
information thank you kelsey